[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  united nations to be paid in dollars or  euros  and a number of other currencies  doesn't make any sense to us therefore  i've decided within a very short period  to introduce a number of measured  measures to  move payments  for our natural gas  to  deliv delivered to the so-called hostile  countries for russian rubles that is  to refuse to use  all the compromised currencies in such  settlements  vision  [Music]  could you explain or could you outline  how nato defends itself against a  nuclear attack  russia must stop its  nuclear saber rattling  this is dangerous and it is  irresponsible  nato is there to protect and defend all  allies  and we convey a very clear message to  russia that the nuclear war can not be  won and should never be fought